i would like to welcome you to this
webinar on the seven myths of venture
capital
tips for new and aspiring entrepreneurs
with mike levick and ashmit siddhana
mike is an associate professor of civil
and environmental engineering
and a senior fellow at the woods
institute for the environment
at stanford university he is also the
academic
director of the stanford i2m program
ashmeat is a longtime venture capitalist
and is the founder and chief engineer of
engineering capital
his experience includes managing venture
capital funds
ceo he serves on multiple boards and is
an experienced
entrepreneur hush meat received his mba
from the wharton school of business
he has a ms in computer science from
stanford university
and a bs in computer science from usc
ashmite is an action traveler and has
summited mount everest
for more information about mike and
ashley's experience
please check out stanford online
webpages
with that i'm going to hand the webinar
over to mike and ashmead
mike thanks thanks anita
um it's wonderful to to
join you here today um i i know that uh
today we truly have a a global webinar
um in that uh in that you're joining
from your home in
in beautiful palo alto and i'm i'm
joining from a uh
from seoul uh right now um uh
traveled here yesterday uh to uh to work
at our research center focused on smart
cities
uh and so we truly have a global
president a presence for for this for
this webinar um
so one of the things that i wanted to
talk to you today about
were uh were some of these myths about
venture capital
and you know i think that venture
capital is
one of those very sort of mythologic
jobs uh it is such such that
people don't know exactly what it is but
it sounds
very cool and and and and almost has
sort of a a romantic view to it in that
in that oh my gosh you're picking these
companies you're taking up through
there's billionaires and private jets
and all these other things
uh and and what we want to try to do
here is
number one talk to an actual venture
capitalist and
and talk a bit more about maybe you know
walking back some of those
myths about what venture capital is and
and about what venture capital more
importantly uh is not
and so uh we'll we'll kind of do this uh
david letterman style for those that
remember uh david letterman late night
except he needed top 10 reasons to get
through any specific topic
uh here we think we can do it in seven
uh
and so and so we'll try to we'll try to
get there
so uh the the first um uh so first of
all well welcome welcome ash meet and
it's really a joy to
to be here with you thank you mike it's
a pleasure to be here
so you know let's so let's start with
number seven
right uh a vc's job
is to help you isn't it the job of the
bc to help you
you know that's a great place to start
because that's a pervasive myth
that vcs like to promote vcs like to
project
that they are there to help you that's
their job that's the marketing and the
advertising
that many venture firms do unfortunately
that
is not the job of a vc um you know
people walk into venture firms and i've
had entrepreneurs directly tell me well
you're gonna help me recruit employees
right
or you're gonna help me get customers
right or how many people
are you gonna help me get a partnership
going with and those are fair questions
and vcs will help in all of those ways
in some ways but that's not the job of
the vc
a vc's job is an investor's job
it is to make money in other words to
buy low
and sell high in a company that an
entrepreneur is starting
and that is the primary focus of the vc
and i think entrepreneurs and vc's
relationships sometimes get way laid
when entrepreneurs don't understand that
while a vc may help you
as a part of making themselves
successful and making themselves a great
investor
their primary job is not to help you
yeah well and you know given given the
structure of the cap table
i mean incentives are aligned the vc
only does well if you do well
but but there is absolutely a a
a separation of duties and and and good
corporate governance
um in in that you know the vincent is
very much like a member or
actually officially a member of the
board of directors
at a company which it is not the member
is it's not it's not the board of
directors
um and members of the of the board to
help the ceo
you know find employees for a large
fortune 500 company or any size of
company there is that separation of
powers in good corporate governance
and i think what you're saying is you
have to view this in very much the same
way
absolutely at the formal level you're
right there's a separation of powers
there is a governance system that is
implicit over there
but also in a more subtle and a nuanced
way you can see people get misaligned
and here are two great examples when
uber
was on its hyper growth trajectory
benchmark
very high quality early stage firm was
an investor
on the board and eventually benchmark
sued the ceo the founder ceo travis
so threatened to file a lawsuit showed
up you know in front of
his hotel room at eight o'clock at night
in chicago there's a lot of stories
about this and they're all true
all are not true but there's many of
them are true about what happened and
that's a case where you had a board
member
actively working against a ceo
and i think that starts to tease apart
you know where this relationship
can end up they all don't end up there
hopefully you'll stay aligned hopefully
you will build large and successful
companies
but you do need to start with this
premise that the vc has a different role
and you have a different role as an
entrepreneur
yeah absolutely absolutely um but but
you're you're exactly right when when
you say that there is this
there is this myth that oh yeah this is
going to be somebody who's going to work
for me
in addition to giving me some money and
allowing me to
you know build my company and they're
going to be a just a part of the working
team
not exactly not exactly it does happen
in that
case but not always for sure
for sure um uh and and then i i guess
that that
ties in with you know recognizing that
different vcs are are talented
in different ways and have different
skill sets and and and so
i know we're going to get a little bit
later to to some of the types of advice
that a vc can give you but
they may not even be able to offer you
the kind of help that you
may need or think that you need at that
time
exactly right yeah
all right number six a vc
will tell you why they actually passed
they won't this is another myth you know
people will say
uh that you know xyz told me that you
know this is why they pass
uh passing of course refers to a vc
declining to invest in your company
and entrepreneurs will sometimes to
their credit
ask a vc you know why did you pass why
are you not investing in my company
and there are rare occasions when vcs
will tell you
the actual reason and there are even
rarer occasions where they will tell you
the complete reason
on why they passed but that really is
rare
the vcs incentives unfortunately are not
aligned
to sharing that information at the
simplest level
venture is an investing job there's an
information asymmetry
and so you don't want that information
to go out there a vc does not want to
share exactly what their thought process
is
what their investment criteria is how
they evaluated someone
a nicer and a benign reason is that a vc
may just want to keep a relationship
with you you know they don't want to
hurt your feelings you know they thought
the ceo wasn't good
and they don't want to tell them to
their face that they didn't think they
were good
um and so it could be something as
simple as that
but there are also many more reasons
which range the gamut of you know the
partner has a different agenda the firm
has a different agenda the strategy is
changing
there are venture firms that in the
business we like to call the living dead
in other words venture firms that don't
really have more capital to deploy
uh that are just taking meetings to keep
their reputation
to keep their presence in the market in
the hope that they would raise a new
fund in the future
and there are pernicious effects like
that that
do pervade the market and so it's very
hard to find out the real and actual
reason why someone passed
now obviously if you could find it out
it's very useful information
so i always encourage my entrepreneurs
to go and ask you have nothing to
lose but whatever you hear take it with
a pinch of salt
and try to collect multiple data points
and then try to triangulate and see
what is the real reason is there some
learning in it
that you can get because this is the
reason why
the venture firm passed on you uh my
rule of thumb
is you need 10 knows to really figure
out
what's going on in the market and here's
a piece of advice
if you already have an investor who you
can trust
who is a vc or who knows how the venture
community works
a great way to find out why someone
actually passed
is to ask them to do a back channel in
effect a reverse reference
and say okay you know hey john you
passed on my company
can you let me know why and often a vc
out of professional courtesy
out of you know a relationship which
hopefully your existing
investor has built with the firm will be
able to glean some more truths over
there
but again that is with the caveat that
it should be taken with a pinch of salt
and is
probably not the complete truth on what
actually happened over there
you know i think it's interesting that
you're talking about the living dead and
you know
we talk about zombie companies very
often you know those that are just kind
of hanging on but they can't get that
next round and nothing seems to be
moving forward
and and we don't think about the flip
side of it uh
in in in which there are sort of the
living dead or
zombie you know the venture funds um
which which as you said don't have any
more capital to deploy
but they're looking to raise that next
round and because
all of this is so much about reputation
and about that ability to bring in
the next really great founder they need
to keep that up and so it can be
it can be somewhat confusing to say gosh
i thought you really liked my company i
thought
things were really going well and yet
you couldn't write a check well or you
didn't write a check but
in honesty you couldn't write a check
and that's really interesting
that's exactly right they couldn't write
a check even if they wanted to
and the problem of zombie firms in
venture capital
is particularly bad because
traditionally venture firms are raised
with a 10-year fund cycle
and as long as you are an active manager
you get paid
fees for those entire 10 years in other
words you're getting an income from the
fund
and so it is your interest as a vc to
pretend
that you are active to keep drawing on
those fees which can be substantial if
there are substantial funds
uh even if you don't intend to raise
another fund
or you don't want to do it now here of
course i'm clearly impugning the
objectives of someone who behaves like
that
and the motives of someone who behaves
like that but look we're all human vcs
are human
and we suffer from these weaknesses and
i think it's it would behoove an
entrepreneur to recognize that that
could be going on in the market
i should also add that right now we are
in a very positive market for venture
capital
we've had a great bull run for the last
10 years the market has been up and to
the right it has approved to the benefit
of venture capital
uh kovitt was obviously an enormous
tragedy
in huge parts of the world but it
actually helped venture capital and
technology in some ways
and so if anything it has even further
accelerated the flow of capital towards
vc and so i think the problem of zombie
firms is actually not so bad right now
but if and when the market corrects and
believe me
the market will correct we just we just
don't know where
i can guarantee it it will correct the
only question is when
um at that point i think this will
become once again a very
uh a very big problem yeah no with
interest rates being so low
uh there is so much liquidity and
looking for any kind of return
even even though it might be something
very risky like like uh investing in an
adventure fund
that um that you're right it has been
that that market and and when it will
correct
uh and we've seen it a few times in in
in the sort of the silicon valley space
um it will be it will be uh it will be
challenging
i think one of the other things that you
had said was you always want to be nice
to
people who are coming in and pitching to
you because you never know if they're
going to be the person coming to you
with that next great idea
and so you want to build those
relationships over time
you know a question came in um about
specifically and
and since we're talking about why you
would pass or why you might not pass
advice to female founders of tech
companies
particularly coming from latin america
but more generally to female founders
what are you looking for in this type of
profile
so you know my perception is that it's
unfortunate but female founders do have
a higher bar or a higher burden
just because of the nature of society
just because of the social norms that we
live in and the expectations
that have developed i think uh the good
news is that there are vcs who are
working actively to correct
there are people who are very aware of
this issue and so
there are both sides to this coin but
net net i would say today
there is a higher bar and a higher
burden that you know they just need to
be aware of when they walk into the
market this is a marketplace for ideas
it's a marketplace for money when you're
raising when you're talking to vcs
so you have to be aware of it you know
my mentor the person who i
owe the most to being a vc was actually
a woman catherine gould
who was one of the very first gps in
silicon valley
and was the founder of a great firm
helped me start engineering capital
eventually
and just a fabulous venture capitalist
and a woman
who started a venture firm because she
was
unable to become a partner in a great
fur
and felt that that was the only
alternative left for her
and so she definitely you know had a
chip on her shoulder and she would often
get this question because just by virtue
of being a woman we see a lot of
women entrepreneurs would walk in and so
you would meet a lot of women
entrepreneurs
and her advice you could simplify it
down to
saying that the best course of action
is for female founders to be relatively
oblivious
to this distinction that exists your job
as an entrepreneur is to do your best
making yourself more aware of this issue
is not going to solve the problem
if your goal is to solve the problem
then there are better ways to solve it
in other words you could become a
politician you could become a lawyer you
could become a social activist you could
become
a journalist there are many ways in
which you can address these issues that
are more effective
and probably will have a greater impact
faster
by being an entrepreneur you are simply
setting an example
and your job as an entrepreneur is to
succeed and build your company
that's job one that's job two that is
the most important thing you can do for
yourself
and the world is if you can make that
company successful if you're an
entrepreneur
and so once you make that leap then it
just reduces to what does it take to
make your company successful
what is the best course of action that
you need to take to make your business
and your company successful
and whether you're a female entrepreneur
uh you know
an entrepreneur who has comes from a
different background
a non-traditional background is in a
non-traditional location you mentioned
latin america obviously
which is you know obviously a
non-traditional location to those of us
who are sitting here in silicon valley
but those are giant markets those are
emerging markets
those are fast growing markets and
that's often where there's more
opportunity
and so you just have to play by the
rules of the game as they are
placed in front of you and do the best
you can
yeah definitely um so uh a
a quick funny question that uh that kind
of uh
came in that um is it is a very
interesting question
you know very often i know that there
are investors that kind of
a few years in think to themselves oh
man i don't know if i invested in this
company correctly
i don't know if this was a good i mean
we we all have a little bit of buyer's
remorse from time to time and then one
of the questions that came in
as a founder is it possible to lay off a
vc if you don't want them anymore
that gets a little harder with the cap
table
yes very very hard uh like i the way i
say it is there is no undo
in the venture business uh as an
investor once you make an investment you
are
pretty much committed uh and you're not
gonna get to you know back out of that
similarly as an entrepreneur once you've
selected a vc
and you brought them onto your cap table
there's no undo
you cannot fire an investor um you can
fire
a ceo you can fire a vp you can redo the
the entire management team you can
change your product you can pivot into a
different market
uh you can do all kinds of things but
those cap tables
are pretty rigid and you know can become
board anchors
in some cases and they are definitely a
source of stress
and that is why reputation is so
important that is why diligence
on both sides is so important just like
we do diligence
as we sees before we make an investment
i always
advise my ceos go call some people
off the list in other words not the
reference list that the vc gave you
but go call some people that that vc
worked with in the past
and see what they say behind the back of
the vc
and you will learn a lot uh you will
learn whether that is the kind of person
who you want to work with
that is the kind of person who you will
be aligned with for the long
for the long haul firms have reputations
in addition to partners
you know there are firms who are
friendly and there are firms who play
tough
um there are firms who are playing for
the proverbial home run
and there are firms who are founder
friendly and will accept
you know perhaps a less than optimal
outcome because that's the best strategy
for them and you need to understand that
as an entrepreneur before you accept
that money
because once you take it you're pretty
much in it for life
well and and uh and that also i think
speaks to one of the other questions
that came
in advice for idea stage founders
be careful who you're working with even
very early on
um and and to say hey you know to your
cousin to a friend to somebody in the
family hey i'll i'll give you a half of
the company if you
if you if you do x y and z for me
because
at that point they're an investor as
well in in many regards
because they will be on that cap table
and and they will be there forever
if it's structured that way and so you
want to be very careful very early on
with making sure you are thoughtful
about about who you're going to bring in
and what you're going to offer
it's an incredibly important point yes
mike
the way i think an entrepreneur can
simplify this is that
you know your job obviously as an
entrepreneur is to build a profit and
loss and a balance sheet
uh everybody thinks of a business in
terms of consisting of a pnl and a
balance sheet i'd say well you're really
managing
three statements you're managing your
pnl your balance sheet and your cap
table
and you have to be thoughtful about how
you are going to grow it
there's only 100 to go around that 100
can never change and it really has to
survive the life of the company
and so how are you going to husband the
growth of that cat table
through eventual success whatever your
definition of success an ipo
and mna there's only 100 to go around
over there and it becomes a zero-sum
game
very very quickly and then you are at
odds you are sitting on the opposite
side of the table from someone
who was your friend yesterday and it's
very uncomfortable
that leads to very very difficult
conversations
indeed indeed all right let's let's get
back to the list we're at number five
a vc turning you down means something's
wrong with your business
that's not true this is a huge myth and
one i wish every entrepreneur would take
to heart
before they followed my advice on the
previous one
which is you know go get feedback and
learn what she is saying
if you remember my answer to the
previous question you have to take what
the vc says with a huge grain of salt
and so
that applies to them saying why they
passed
me implying something wrong with your
company in other words don't
over rotate on the feedback that you get
from a vc
sometimes entrepreneurs will say oh they
told me my go-to market is bad
well that's the reason they gave you why
they passed
that doesn't necessarily mean your
go-to-market is wrong
or bad or is not appropriate for the way
you want to build your business
or for the product that you've done they
may not have even understood your
product
they may not have even understood your
strategy or even if they understood it
they may not agree with the risk reward
trade-off of that strategy
even if they agree with the risk award
trade-off with the strategy they may
have chosen not to participate
in that because of other preferences
that they have in their fund or other
companies that they have in their fund
completely unrelated to you in other
words if i've just taken if i'm a large
fund i just take a 10 consumer bets
i may not want to make the 11th consumer
better i may want an enterprise bet for
the 11th one
it has nothing to do with you having a
wrong or a
bad approach to building your business
and so
it's important for an entrepreneur to
have the courage of their convictions
to be able to derive from first
principles that they are building a good
business for the long term
vcs are famous for being parent matchers
they are making quick decisions
they are trying to you know make a
portfolio build a portfolio on their
side
and that is not what you are doing as an
entrepreneur as an entrepreneur you are
building a business
ground up bottoms up step by step
for the long term and following a
non-traditional or an unusual path
is actually many times the right thing
to do
it is the way in which you will build a
disruptive company
and so be very cautious when a vc says
that you are doing something wrong
or interpreting that as necessarily
wrong for you
simply take it as one data point out of
many available to you
to learn about your business to learn
about the environment yes
that is their perception yes that is how
you know one smart person sitting in one
firm
who spent an hour or two with you
thought you were doing
but you're doing that 24 hours a day for
years at an end
and there are lots of examples of uh
companies that were not understood by
vcs early on
um you know the entire open source
landscape is littered
with vcs who thought they would never
build a big business
let's take the very first successful
company red hat red hat was recently
acquired by ibm
for 30 billion dollars the biggest
acquisition in ibm's history i mean 30
billion dollars is a
massive outcome and here's a company
obviously in this case a public company
and a very old company have been around
for a long time
but it started as an open source company
they're all their products you could
download from the internet
uh for free and yet they built uh what
was eventually a 30 billion dollar
outcome over here so there are many ways
to build a company there are many ways
to build a business and you have to be
creative
yeah well and and one of the things that
i think you had
one of the words you had used i think
that is so important for people to
understand is portfolio
you know much like for all of us we have
a personal
investing portfolio where you're going
to invest in some stocks
and some some other things and you're
trying to create
a mix of investments for which you feel
that you're going to get a good risk
return ratio
and and that doesn't mean there aren't
hundreds of
other great companies out there on the
stock market that you could buy
and in many regards they might be just
as good however
if you've already bought one of those
other competitors of theirs you may not
want
to to allocate more of your capital and
sort of you know double down
on that one bet the the venture
capitalist is very much
as you've said before is an investor and
investors
manage portfolios and so you also have
to
understand there may not be nothing
something wrong with you but rather
you're just duplicating a part of their
portfolio and they would choose not to
do this
any any longer i guess maybe as a
follow-up to that
when um when a venture capitalist says
you know i i really i'm going to have to
pass on this
but maybe you should go talk to this
other fund
uh are they giving you an honest
recommendation that they think that
other fund
might invest in you or are they just
kind of passing you off to kind of get
you out of the office and at least i
sent them on their way with some nice
piece of information
like all human communication mike the
answer depends you know
there is no silver bullet that anyone
has developed otherwise you know we
would need a justice system and courts
and
and journalists and investigative
reporters and you know all of this work
to get to the truth of the matter and i
think ultimately of course this becomes
a philosophical question and you know
what is the nature of truth
uh but the answer depends uh you know i
have seen vcs
who will go out of their way to be
helpful and will
genuinely give you feedback um
and then i've seen vcs who can be quite
cynical about it and
would uh you know want to take advantage
of the situation
and perhaps abuse the trust that you may
be placing in them and so
like you know any human population it
ranges
there's an entire range of people and
you as an entrepreneur have to make an
evaluation a judgment
of what it is that you are receiving uh
with you caution
over there vcs do keep a lot of contacts
you know that's part of our job
and so we can give you insight over
there i will tell you having been a
practicing vc now for over a decade
that our fear on the other side of the
table
is that many times entrepreneurs
actually don't want to hear the truth
many times entrepreneurs are not
receptive to
really what they would be able to get
and so it is in our interest to be uh to
demure you know to just be quiet and to
avoid a confrontation there's no reason
to create a confrontation there
and so vcs will sometimes take the low
road in that sense rather than taking
the high road or you could call it the
high road i guess
by just staying quiet over there and so
what i would
tell entrepreneurs is if you can somehow
communicate to the vc
that you are genuinely looking for their
best
recommendation their best advice then
you may get a better answer
but at the end of the day you will have
to evaluate
you know how much weight to put on that
on that recommendation and that answer
yeah no it's that's uh
you're right it always depends right i
mean
what kind of relationship have you built
through those first few discussions
uh and and and whether or not they they
think that
that you're somebody worth spending
spending more time with and and to give
you that advice
all right um number four and this is
one that uh i think is uh indeed a huge
myth
around uh around around the world uh
certainly around uh silicon valley
vcs are rich species aren't rich i mean
come on
well you know there are certainly some
vc's who are rich
but there are also many vcs who are not
rich
and i think it's important to understand
that uh for an entrepreneur who's
walking in who is hoping to build a
relationship
with a firm and with a person um
let's first separate you know whether an
individual is rich or whether a fund has
money which is the money that they are
going to invest in you as an
entrepreneur
those are not one and the same thing you
know a fund is a distinct separate
entity
in which there are lps limited partners
who hopefully and presumably are rich
who have invested in that fund
whether through a foundation or
endowment whether it's a pension fund or
perhaps even a high net worth individual
who has invested in that fund
that is the money that is being invested
in companies
that is distinct and separate from the
individual who is doing the
job of a venture capitalist who is
investing that money
uh venture capital can be a lucrative
business in the long term
and so if you're a good vc eventually
you should be rich
uh that's part of you know the returns
of that job
but many vcs are not rich um especially
vcs
who are junior younger working at large
firms
is where you see the maximum disconnect
that happens
and i have seen it lead to some awkward
situations
uh you know if you can be a stanford mba
who graduates
and you know becomes a principal or an
associate at a very large venture firm
and yes you get a nice salary but you
haven't become rich overnight you know
you just got a job
at a large venture firm which is perhaps
managing billions of dollars
and i was personally in a dinner once
where
someone ordered a thousand dollar bottle
of wine
uh you know just as part of the dinner
you know part of the
conversation that was going on and i
think it was very uncomfortable for the
other person
uh because it was inappropriate i don't
think the entrepreneur had recognized
that you know i mean that's that's a
very large purchase
relative to a casual dinner that someone
may be doing
now there are lots of vcs who wouldn't
think twice about spending a thousand
dollars on a bottle of wine
but there are many vcs who will remember
that and i certainly noticed
the look of chagrin on people's faces
when it happened and so you should not
presume that i think that's incorrect
and just understand that we are just
normal people
who are doing a job in a different line
of work
who are in there who depending on the
stage of career they're on
may be at different stages of wealth
creation for themselves
right which which is not to say that a
junior investor doesn't have money to
invest
they absolutely have decision making
power and things like this
and that goes to that separation between
whether or not they have
investing capability or capacity on
behalf of the fund
versus their personal checkbook um
and such that you know when when you
just start investing as a personal
investor
say in the market or anywhere else
you're not going to have a lot of money
because you're a new investor
and and yet over time you do create that
wealth for yourself
that can then balance that that
lifestyle indeed
mike it's a really good point and i'm
going to insert something that you and i
didn't discuss before which i want to
use this to build on which is venture is
one of those
rare areas where when you are selling
remember when you're
pitching a vc you're basically selling
your stock you're selling a portion of
your company
it is one of those rare industries where
when you are selling
i don't recommend that you necessarily
sell high
the traditional advice when you're
selling is to sell as high as you can
if you're selling to a corporation go to
the ceo go to the cio
if you can't go to a vp if you can't go
to a director
in venture i think there are many
benefits to
actually selling to anyone including
selling low in other words that new
entrant who's straight out of school or
a few years out of work
but if you're working for a high quality
firm that you feel is aligned with what
you are doing
there's a lot to be gained as an
entrepreneur by selling it over there
so i do encourage you in general to
build that relationship to work with
them if all the other checks
make sense but be cognizant that they
just may be in a different stage of
their career
yet may literally be sitting on a
billion dollar checkbook
ready and willing and able to write you
know very large tax
uh to your company yeah well and and
you have participated in another one of
the of the
programs that i that i run at stanford
on venture capital training
um and uh and and so we absolutely
have have worked with a lot of very
brand new investors who are just trying
to figure out how to
best deploy the capital that that
they're that they're
that they've been they've been allocated
which brings up a question that came in
you know given the lack of professional
standards and training and certification
required to be a gp
in a venture fund um you know do you
think there is a space for some kind of
training or certification process for
aspiring gps or or or is
or is the role of the vc or the gp
so broad and so varied that yeah maybe
training and certification like that
wouldn't be quite quite necessary or
what would you look for as far as
maybe a background on a vc that can that
can help you in that way
yeah so i was trained as an apprentice
uh
you know in venture capital and i
learned sort of you know in the
traditional way
where someone literally would sit in
meetings with me
i would follow her to every board
meeting catherine gould i would follow
her to board meetings
and after the board meetings we would
reconstruct the meeting we would listen
to entrepreneurs we would deconstruct
the meeting and say okay what did we
learn how did we learn
etc and at some level there is no
substitute for experience
experience is this very fuzzy notion
of this large amount of you know
contradictory data that you collect
which does lead you to then hopefully
make good judgments
uh and be able to then predict things in
a more interesting way
so given that background i'm skeptical
that you can really have a
certification or a training mechanism a
formal
you know mechanism to complete the
process
can you build a foundation absolutely is
there a benefit to be had through that
absolutely and there is a program which
is very prestigious
and well known called the kauffman
program uh which also
you know provides some some training etc
it's not regulated
there's no certification requirement
over there but it does have a good
reputation
and but they also follow the apprentice
model they are also you know while they
have some formal lectures
a lot of the learning happens in the
real day-to-day meeting
and i don't think we will see a
substitute for that happening anytime
soon
the biggest threat or the biggest
interesting development there really is
the application of
ai or artificial intelligence to
investing
and the question is how much ai can
replace
a vc gp a gps role an investor's role
in a vc i think that's an active area
there's certainly a lot of academic
research going on over there right now
there are some people who are doing
experiments on the periphery of that
but i'm not aware of any firm where
there's a black box ai that makes a
decision you know yes no
decision on an investment uh you know
at least not a successful firm yet that
does that there might be firms that are
trying to do that but i don't know that
we know that
it's been proven out as of yet exactly i
mean you know the best and the most
famous firms that i know of
all have you know living breathing human
beings who are sitting around the table
having that conversation and saying you
know is this the next steve jobs
or is this you know the next you know
idiot who
doesn't dress well and uh it does smells
a little bit when he walked
the meeting and i'm just referring to
the actual feedback that steve jobs
was given after his first meeting with
sequoia capital
about him not having taken the shower
before the meeting and you know
etc so uh you know those types of uh
judgments are very subtle
and and and the thought experiment that
i tell people
to do is how do you distinguish between
someone who is being persistent
and someone who is being obstinate give
me a test for that
and it's very hard to think of a test
you know when someone presents a
decision to you or someone
you know says and you i you know is the
person being persistent or obstinate
with hindsight it's obvious
if with hindsight it becomes very simple
to know that this person should have
given up or should have kept going
but you know a priority it's very very
hard to do that
and that is the job of a vc you know
when someone walks in
my job is to sit there and say that this
grand amazing vision that this person
painted
you know is that a hallucination or is
that really you know a prediction about
what could be achieved in the future
uh and reasonable people disagree you
know reasonable people disagree on
on when presented with that information
that's what makes venture so fun
that's what makes entrepreneurship so
fun
indeed indeed well you know you've
mentioned you mentioned catherine a few
times um
which which belies your your uh your
your your you know
long relationship with foundation
capital and and all your work there and
and then now um uh of course your your
new your new uh
firm engineering capital um question
came in
how do i apply for engineering capital
yes uh you know i'm very defined so
thank you
uh thank you mike i'm very easy to find
you can find me on
on the web at engineeringcapital.com and
i have a
contact form if you want to fill that
out i do read all
the entries that come in through that
contact form so
uh it's easy to find me over there and
you can also find me on twitter
at meat sadhana or linkedin i mean i'm
easy to find
on the internet in fact most pcs are
relatively easy to find
that said i will caution anyone who's
watching
that i now have an incredibly narrow
focus you know engineering capital is a
labor of love for me
this is i only do at engineering capital
what i love doing
which is very early stage software
companies
that are taking technical risk and it's
primarily in the bay area or certainly
in the u.s that my focus is
so it's a very narrow practice if you
feel it's a match for that
please do reach out and i would be happy
to review your plan and see if it's a
fit for my fund i'm certainly
actively investing right now yeah no
that's that's that's great all right
so back to the list number three
so vcs aren't rich but investing in vc
will make you rich yes this is the flip
side of the coin
for the previous point which is you know
so if people believe that all vcs are
rich
maybe they also believe that you know
investing in vc is always a good idea
uh look there's a lot of venture funds
out there and especially in the last 10
years we've seen an explosion in the
number of smaller newer funds
and an explosion in the size of the
larger funds so the total capital going
into venture has gone up dramatically
and as mike as you also said right now
interest rates are zero effectively
and so you're really competing with zero
as the alternative and everything looks
good
relative to zero as long as you're not
losing money
uh here's the here's the sad truth the
average venture firm loses money
the average venture firm actually has
negative returns
so you know let that sink in that's a
really
really poor investment if you are going
to invest in
average venture capital tends to follow
the power law
in other words all the returns are
concentrated right at the top
and they are disproportionately high in
other words if you can be in a vin
with a winning venture fund and a really
venture firm
you could make enormous returns much
higher than you could make
in a traditional investment whether in
the public markets or even in the
private markets
you can do extremely well in those rare
funds
but the key word there is rare and the
key word there are power law
and so you really have to understand
what you're getting into
and so be very cautious if you are
investing in a venture fund
while disproportionate returns are
possible they're very risky
and even the largest most sophisticated
institutional investors
rarely invest more than three four five
percent of their entire corpus
in venture farms and so that should tell
you how risky
it is um you can actually go and see
what numbers
uh i don't know it off the top of my
head you know what the stanford
endowment the
yale endowment etc these are very
sophisticated investors
who have an infinite time horizon tens
of billions of dollars to invest
and yet they only allocate one two three
four percent of their endowments
typically to venture
and that will give you a sense for how
risky it is so
yes it can be very lucrative yes it's
the only place where you could make five
times your money ten times your money
twenty times your money those are not
inconceivable those happen in venture
uh even hundred times has happened in
venture
uh in terms of investing in venture
funds but again be very cautious what
you're getting into this is
high risk capital well and and i think
you know
one one of the things we talk about in
our venture capital training program is
that one of the most common job titles
in silicon valley is a former venture
capitalist
because um uh you know yes in indeed
most funds the average fund does not
return
uh and and because of that strong skew
uh it makes it seem like it's a very you
know
not easy but but a very attractive uh
investment space uh and unless you
understand that very strong power law
uh it can seem somewhat somewhat um
disenchanting when it doesn't work out
quite right so yeah in
indeed not investing in bc will not make
you rich
uh in all cases um
all right number two we're getting down
to the last couple you know vcs know
and can give you good operating advice
they can't you don't know how to run
your business for me come on
you know this is the default approach
that most venture firms took
traditionally and continue to take for
the vast majority today
which is that we are good operators we
are x operators
we used to be ceos we used to run
companies we are x engineers we are x
sales people
uh and therefore we are now good vcs and
so
you know we will give you good operating
advice i myself was a ceo before i
myself ran product management for
you know a significant part of vmware
before etc
and so you would think that i have good
operating advice to offer you
and in some cases yes but again the key
word there is some
not always and because vcs
will sometimes use their operating
background
as a marketing vehicle as a mechanism to
attract
entrepreneurs to come and choose them as
their investors
they will oversell their operating
abilities
and the application of those operating
capabilities to you as an entrepreneur
and so you have to be very careful when
that happens
one of the most painful experiences for
me is to sit in a board meeting
to have someone who is a relatively
newer vc or someone who's only been
doing it for two three four years
who was perhaps a great vp of sales or a
great vp of engineering
giving advice on sales or engineering
their supposed area of expertise to a
ceo
and that advice just not being
applicable you know
the situation is different the
technology is different
the company is different the market is
different the style of the ceo is
different their preferences are
different the culture
is different there are so many things
that can be different and here you have
someone who's parachuted in
who thinks their job is to give you
operating advice
and because they sit in a position of
power
usually vcs will take board seats they
have governance controls etc
and so people will defer to them you
know when they give those advice and
it's very dangerous you really really
should be very cautious
both giving advice if you're a vc and
receiving advice if you're a ceo
on the operating side again great vcs
can do it in great situations it is
appropriate
and there is something to be had over
there that's why it exists and persists
but don't assume that vcs will
necessarily give you great operating
advice
or that is necessarily the right course
of action for your company
you are living and breathing that
business day in and day out
the best entrepreneurs leverage the
operating advice
of the vc rather than take the advice so
for example i have had
great ceos walk in and say okay here's
my sales situation
i'm stuck over here you go make this
happen for me they make the vc work for
you you know they will have a certain
task a certain
introduction a certain question that has
to be answered
and they will make the vc work for you
that is the best way for you to engage
as an entrepreneur with the vc
not as your someone who you work for
well and this gets back to the first one
we have talked about a vc's job is to
help you
coming in and saying i really need help
my marketing isn't working
is very different than saying i need
this one thing can you please help me
with this very specialized task so if
someone came to you
as an investor and asked you to do that
that would not be
that you you would not feel that was
inappropriate or strange
with a very narrow focus thing for which
you had a skill set that you could
actually
complete that for them mike you framed
it beautifully
but the narrower you can make the ass
the more effective the vc is likely to
be
and the more valuable the the input and
more correct
more likely it is to be correct in terms
of the interaction that happens
here's a test that you can use when
someone gives you advice
how easy is it to disagree with that
advice how easy is it to say
no that it's the wrong answer and why
how do you feel that way
the the easier it is the better it is
the more useful it can be
in that interaction so if you can narrow
something down all the way to i want to
talk to john smith
at xyz inc for this reason
that's it obviously perhaps over an
arrow but an incredibly
actionable and and someone can say yes i
know john or no i don't know john and
that's a yes no binary answer at that
point
um so you need to make it that narrow uh
obviously
typically you would have a product
conversation hopefully a little bit less
narrower than that
but that is really the level at which i
think operating questions should be
discussed
with vcs at the end of the day you are
the ceo
you are the entrepreneur it's your
company it's your business
and you have to make it successful the
way i like to say is
a vc's reputation doesn't make a company
successful
a company's success makes a vc's
reputation
so if i invest in a company and that
company is the next google or the next
facebook or the next
vmware of course that makes my
reputation as a vc but just because
i invested in companies which have gone
public and returned hundreds of millions
of dollars
etc etc and i give you a million dollars
that's not going to make your company
successful
you have to build your own success out
of that
no that's that's a very interesting
that's a very interesting take that i
think you know a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs think that if i agree
if i get a really great investment from
sequoia that's going to make everything
that much easier i'll be able to shop
that brand name around and
while that does provide a little bit of
you know a little bit of confidence and
maybe
somewhat part of the due diligence for
later rounds uh no
you have to build your own company you
will make the investor look great it's
not the other way around and
i think that's a that's a that's a
really great great point you know going
back to
going back to some some of your past
history at foundation
uh there was a question what does an
operating partner do
yeah so maybe i'll uh answer the broader
question of what do these titles all
mean in a venture firm operating partner
is obviously one popular title
a venture partner is another title
general partner or managing director
is probably the most common title that
people use and sometimes there are
hierarchical titles like associate
principal vice president
etc that people use so
the short answer to titles in general is
it just depends every firm has their own
culture
there is really no norm around titles
and you
have to figure it out so here's how you
you can figure it out as an entrepreneur
usually a managing director or a general
partner title
uh is the real deal right those titles
are only given to people who really are
general partners or managing directors
you don't have them
you know unless they really are a
general partner and so if you're talking
to someone who's got that title you're
done
you know you answered your question you
really don't have to do a lot more
research over there
usually there are a few exception cases
of zombie partners or zombie firms but
let's put those in the minority case all
the other titles
they are not equal to a general partner
or a managing director that's why they
have that type
and so you have to figure it out for
that particular firm
what that title means and how are they
interpreting it and how they are using
it
i can't give you a thumb rule for any
firm
and what's even worse is that these
titles evolve over time
so what happens is firms grow and change
and they still keep using their own
title that they use
and so you really have to go ask that
person what does this really mean
and here's a polite way in which you can
ask that question uh because it's
sort of rude to ask someone you know
sort of what their title really means
are you you mean it's rude to ask are
you the real deal
i mean you know it's kind of hard to ask
someone like you know
your business card doesn't say general
partner should i be spending time with
you
you know what is the goal of this
meeting over here for me
um and so you know the polite way to ask
the question
is to say what is your decision making
process
okay not criteria they'll rarely give
you the criteria but process
and then try to narrow it down to what
those action items are
so for example almost all large firms
almost inevitably have a partner meeting
as usually the tail end of the process
or perhaps the very last step of the
process
okay so you really want to understand
well what do i have to do to get a
partner meeting
uh and what does it take you know how
how how will i know that you are ready
to give me a term sheet or you will give
me a term sheet
the outcome of a conversation with the
vc that you want
is a term sheet that is the tangible
physical
outcome which is success for you as an
entrepreneur
and so you really want to map that
process out and questions like
how long will it take what is the next
step
how many steps are there you know those
are all polite ways
of really understanding it and you owe
it to your yourself as an entrepreneur
to
be crystal clear about it do not leave
any meeting
with avc without knowing what the next
step is otherwise you just wasted your
time
you know because you know it is in the
vc's interest to take meetings you know
our job is to meet entrepreneurs
and we can walk away saying oh well i
learned about one more business
i learned about a new market i learned
about a new product i learned about a
new team
and that's a net positive for me for you
it's a net negative
you just taught someone about your
business about your market and you may
not get anything out of that return
unless it progresses to a term sheet or
in some rare cases advice that you may
get out of that
and so you really want to stay focused
on the goal and keep it in a very sales
driven process you know there's a
there's a thumb rule in sale abc always
be closing
right you have to follow the abc
principle it's like okay what are the
steps to a term sheet because if that's
not happening
you're not clear what you're doing
you're just wasting your time
yeah and and just to be clear for
everybody uh at engineering capital ash
meat is the real deal
uh just you don't have to know that that
that that's in fact the case
all right so our final i i did i do want
to make one more point
on that it's a really important point
you bring up in my case i'm the only
partner and so it's very easy and i have
fun with the title over there
some firms will deliberately obscure
who the real partners are from the you
know from sort of the morris
the more assistance or helping partners
by using generic titles like partner
for everyone when everyone is a partner
you know there are some people
who carry the partner title who are not
partners
uh and you know your job as an
entrepreneur is to figure that out
so i'm sorry it's unfortunate but you
know it's just part of the landscape
that's how the industry has evolved
uh and there are good strategic reasons
why it helps
the firms to do it and so i do believe
this behavior will persist
and you will see more of this not less
of this
indeed all right and our number one
thing and you seem like such a friendly
guy
dc's are your friend not true
thank you mike i'll take it as a
compliment uh that you think of me as
friendly and let's face it you know most
vcs have a good demeanor
you know we choose for good
interpersonal skills good relationship
skills
because it's a relationship business
that is what allows us
to work with entrepreneurs who are
working in a very stressful situation
who are taking on a disruptive difficult
task
that they are trying to build from uh
in an environment that is by definition
difficult that's why it's interesting if
it was easy
it wouldn't be lucrative it would not
have high returns
and so uh in an environment like that
our job is to be to be the friend of the
entrepreneur to work with the
entrepreneur and to keep those
relationships
but the fundamental relationship is not
that of a friend
and i think entrepreneurs sometimes get
fooled by that
because we work like this because we are
very informal
because we are casual because you know
we're always doing dinner or beer
or hanging out or you know and it's it's
the the
and to some extent because especially in
california our interpersonal our working
styles are very casual
uh and that sort of breeds this this
feeling that they are your friend
and i'll circle this all the way back to
the very first
example i gave where benchmark was suing
uber or threatening to sue uber
or that is not something that friends do
to each other
you don't stay friends if you do that
and so
so if a vc is not your friend then what
is your relationship with your vc
and i think you can be clear and you
should understand that
number one clearly he's your investor he
or she
is sitting on your cap table and
when you talk to her at the end of the
day you know she's your investor he's
your investor they're looking at it
as a shareholder in the company but they
may also be your board member and so
they may have a governance role with you
and you have to be aware of that power
dynamic as a board member they may be
your partner in the sense that you are
aligned in your long-term goals they
want the company to succeed you want the
company to succeed
you are aligned and so you could build a
partnership where you are a team
where they can be a thought leader with
you perhaps a sparring
partner with you who can work with you
in that role perhaps they are your
mentor
you know they have a lot more experience
and while i was dissing the experience
earlier in terms of it's not always
applicable
let's face it you know i've got gray
hair i've fought a lot of battles
i've seen a lot of issues come up and i
may be able to give some advice which is
useful
and so they could be a mentor and you
can have a mentor mentee
relationship over here you should be
aware of those things
they may also be your competitor
okay they may they have a portfolio they
may have an
investment and it sometimes happens
explicitly or implicitly that they have
a competing investment
laws so you have to be aware of that
they may be
your enemy your goals may not be aligned
okay which is how you know you may end
up eventually literally fighting each
other
but they can become you and you do see
very stressful situations
in boards where it is clear that the
goals are not aligned
and therefore there is a political
situation a power situation and they are
your enemy over there
so there is an entire range of
relationships that can develop over
there
and i think your job as an entrepreneur
is to always understand
what is the current relationship what is
the best relationship
how best to benefit that and grow with
that remembering
that it is a extremely rare chance that
they are actually your friend
when they have that relationship with
you and and
you know i started off by saying that
you know ashmi seems so friendly and it
is wonderful to have him as
as a friend thank you very much for
joining us for today's
webinar um and uh and and these sort of
top seven myths to to try to you know
demystify a bit of venture capital
please check him out
at engineering capital the the fun that
he runs anita i'm going to hand it back
to you for just
a a short wrap-up very quickly um
i want to thank you mike and ashmi um
for this very eye-opening revealing
honest conversation it's been very very
helpful
i think it's giving some insight many
insights um and before we go to our
audience
um if you'd like to learn more about the
idea to market
entrepreneurship program you can click
on the button on this page the next
session
will begin on august 30th thank you
all for joining us today and we wish you
a very great day thanks
thank you mike thank you anita
you